[Music]
tom is with us tom's in salt lake city
how are you tom
i'm doing great how are you better than
i deserve what's up
so uh my wife and i are um at the the
end of the baby steps where we're
debt-free uh thankfully in large part to
uh to you and your program and and uh
just some crazy life experiences that
enabled us to get there we worked real
hard and that's where we're at now
um
so we are
both now looking into our retirement uh
and both of us started this whole
journey
in in our 30s and so our
and our retirement investments were
rather kind of pretty delayed we didn't
start investing until you know like i
said our early early 30s
and so what we have now is
uh we started with a fairly modest
income uh now my wife works and i own my
own business and we have a
a
much larger income than we had before so
what's your household income now
right now we're close to 400. wow look
at you how old are you again
i'm 39. oh wow amazing you're ancient i
can't believe you're getting around and
um i know yeah and uh and how much do
you have in retirement
uh after we so after this year we'll
have about uh about a hundred good for
you good okay and uh how much debt do
you have
we are debt-free it's taken us eight
years
and everything everything's gone
everything's gone house and everything
yep way to go dude
way to go what's the house worth
i personally think it's worth probably
about 400 or so but the market says that
it's about 650. so well i mean the
market is it gets to the side you don't
get to decide
so i'm calling it 650 then good for you
man well done well done and you're
making a bank what a great business you
do at this is awesome so now all you got
to do you're what we call baby step
seven so now y'all all you gotta do
stack up cash now dude and with a four
hundred thousand dollar shovel you ought
to be able to stack it up pretty fast
that's what we're we're really excited
about and we're looking at potentially
retiring
in the next 10 years yeah for sure so
what's your question today
sounds like you're doing great my
question today yeah well
my question really is
um as far as the 15
of your income into retirement that
doesn't apply to you you're a baby step
seven that's only when you're on baby
step four you can ramp that up once you
get the house paid that's what i needed
to hear yeah baby step seven is save as
much as you can
give as much as you can
live as much as you are in your plan
oh that
sounds so great for to hear you say that
if we if we dump in you know 100 150 a
year into this into this uh investment
firm that um that we found through
your smartvestor pros um they're helping
us out because i am
very investment unsavvy so they're
they're guiding us through that yeah um
if we just dump in 150 a year then where
their forecast says that within 10 years
we could
retire as multi-millionaires and live
authentication yeah you'll probably have
a couple million in that alone and the
house will be worth a couple million
then
so yeah i mean you're going to be 400 4
million net worth at 50 years old is
what it sounds like to
me it's good you see that yeah i mean if
you if you keep making this kind of bank
and you drop 150 in there i mean 150 for
10 years is a million and a half plus
the growth during that time is easily
another half million probably another
million actually
so 10 10 10 times 150 is 1.5 million
dude okay
39 to 49 exactly
so that's what that's exactly what we're
looking at yeah you don't have to have
like a calculator or anything to do that
you can do that one in your head so then
then you just add some you know the
growth that you're going to make on top
of that during that time is astronomical
and so
yeah there's another million easy on
there
in growth and growth yeah
uh double every about seven years or so
you're going to be in great shape just
work with your smart mr pro keep laying
out a plan shovel the cash over there
and uh here's the trick
is to avoid getting arrogant in the
middle of this
and blowing it up before you get there
that's the trick because what happens is
you look over there and you got a
million dollar paid for house and you
got a couple million dollars a million
dollars laying in mutual funds in your
retirement and then you go i can afford
to go do this stupid thing now and
people can you can blow the whole thing
up by derailing just
dance with the girl that brought you
stick with the program
the you know dance with the one that
brought you to the ball just stick with
the program don't get over here and go
oh now now i'm going to bitcoin is now
my aunt put it all in doge you know
people they get you get a little bit of
hubris and suddenly your brain just
fries out so just don't do that just
mutual funds and paid for real estate
just keep it simple and stack cash and
you're going to be in really good shape
man you've done a great job and largely
because a you're paying attention and b
you're making a lot of money it's a big
shovel that helps yeah
very nice